hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter fairy
today we'll be discussing the history of
Gringotts visiting Bank as well as the
magical money that it uses to fuel the
Wizarding economy Gringotts was first
founded in the late 15th century during
the year of 1474 by a goblin who went by
the name you guessed it gringott little
is known about the Goblin gringott and
his formative years or even how old he
was when he found the bank that would
become the safest place for valuables in
The Wizarding World
what we do know is that he is featured
on his own chocolate frog card alongside
the likes of famous witches and wizards
such as Albus Dumbledore and Merlin in a
small way this signifies the incredible
accomplishment gringott achieved by
creating the first ever bank for Magical
Society the bank itself is located on
the north side of the Hidden Locale
Diagon Alley a street magically
concealed from Muggles and only visited
by those who are part of the Wizarding
World accessible via the Wizarding pump
the Leaky cauldron which sits upon the
Muggle Road of Charing Cross Road
Gringotts is one of the most frequented
magical establishments within Central
London this of course is due to the fact
that Gringotts is the only Wizarding
Bank in Britain meaning that any witch
or wizard who wishes to keep their gold
or other valuables safe inside a proper
magical bank would need to travel to
Britain and visit gring Gods to do so of
course this is rather unbelievable to us
Muggles who seem to have a bank on every
other Street which is made clear by
Harry's reaction the first time Hagrid
tells him of gringott's existence nah
first stop for us is Gringotts Wizards
Bank have a sausage they're not bad cold
and I wouldn't say no to a bit of your
birthday cake neither Wizards have Banks
just the one Gringotts run by goblins
Harry dropped the bit of sausage he was
holding goblins well perhaps Harry was
actually more surprised by Hagrid's
mention of goblins but I digress
immediately noticeable to anyone who
steps foot into Diagon Alley Gringotts
is taller than every other shop on the
street and has a brilliant white
exterior with a set of bronze outer
doors all of which Harriet Myers as he
approaches the bank for the first time
gringott said Hagrid they had reached a
snowy white building which towered of
the other little shops standing beside
its burnished bronze doors wearing a
uniform of scarlet and gold was yeah
that's a goblin said quietly as they
walked up the white stone steps towards
him then just inside the bronze exterior
doors is a second set of inner doors
silver and material and colors with the
following words of warning engraved upon
them
enter stranger but take heed of what
awaits the sin of greed for those who
take but do not earn must pay most
dearly in their turn so if you seek
beneath our flaws a treasure that was
never yours Thief you have been warned
beware of finding more than treasure
there
through these silver doors and upon
actually entering the inner Hall of the
building visitors are met by a large
space made entirely of marble behind one
long counter there are more than 100
high top stools made for the Goblins who
work there to sit upon and deal with the
bank's patrons and leading off the
Marvel Hall are too many doors to count
presumably since its opening Gringotts
has been run by goblins however it would
seem that not long after it opened its
doors the ministry of magic assumed
management of the bank the exact date of
this takeover is unknown but in the
centuries that followed it is one of the
many controversies that have fueled the
conflict between goblins and wizard kind
despite the ministry having hand in
running Gringotts and witches and
wizards being the primary clientele of
the bank goblins do continue to run the
establishment in a way that no other
species can
aside from the fact that goblins have an
innate ability to understand finances in
the economy they are also able to wield
one less magic that is beyond the grasp
of witches and wizards it is through
this specific brand of Magic the Goblins
are able to keep the valuables that have
been deposited in Gringotts safe for
example while some vaults use tiny
golden keys to access the contents such
as Harry's Vault there are other more
secure vaults that require the magical
Touch of a goblin who was employed by
the bank in order to open their doors
this is the case with both Bellatrix the
strangers vault which Harry Ron and
Hermione access with the help of the
goblin grip hook in 1998 and Albus
Dumbledore's Vault 713 which Hagrid
retrieves the Philosopher's Stone from
in 1991. once again alongside the Goblin
greppunk stand back said grip hook
importantly he stoked the door gently
with one of his long fingers and it
simply melted away
anyone with a Gringotts Goblin tried
that they'd be sucked through the door
and trapped in there said grubhook how
often do you check to see if anyone's
inside Harry asked about once every 10
years said grip hook with a rather nasty
grin and to access any of these vaults
with Gringotts one must first descend
underground as the majority of the bank
actually sprawls deep below the city of
London upon leaving the marbled entrance
hall patrons of the bank find themselves
in a maze of cavernous tunnels lit only
by torches and which carry on for miles
navigation to the steeply descending
tunnels is done via small mine-like
carts that only Gringotts goblins are
able to operate and which can only go at
one speed the deeper down you go the
more highly secure the vaults become
alongside an underground Lake in Ravine
there are also incredibly powerful
enchantments used to prevent thieves
from successfully robbing the bank from
what little we know some of these spells
and enchantments include the thief's
downfall which is a waterfall that
descends upon any number of paths that
the mine-like can't travel and
effectively washes away all magic from
whomever is occupying the cart some of
the higher security vaults also use
magical defenses such as the gemino and
flagrante curses which when placed on an
item of value Burns to the touch and
then multiplies making worthless copies
of the item these magical defenses are
just some of the presumed enchantments
placed on the vaults and within the Maze
of tunnels meant to deter people from
trying to rob Gringotts which is further
explained by Hagrid to Harry back in
1991 before they visited the bank for
the first time yeah so you'd be mad to
try and Rob it I'll tell you that never
mess with goblins Harry Gringotts is the
safest place in the world for anything
you want to keep safe Zapped may be
Hogwarts why would you be mad to try and
Rob Gringotts Harry asked spells
enchantments said Hagrid unfolding his
newspaper as he spoke they say there's a
dragon guarding the high security vaults
and then you've got to find your way
Gringotts is hundreds of miles under
London see deep under the underground
you die of hunger trying to get out even
if you did manage to get your hands on
something
oh yes and there's also a dragon while
for many the dragon guarding the Deep
bolts of Gringotts is only a myth Harry
Ron and Hermione discovered for certain
that it was incredibly real when they
broke into Gringotts in 1998 a gigantic
Dragon was Tethered to the ground in
front of them barring access to four or
five of the deepest vaults in the place
the beast's scales had turned to pale
and Flaky during its long incarceration
under the ground its eyes were milkily
pink both rear legs bore heavy cuffs
from which chains led to enormous pegs
driven deep into the rocky floor
great spiked Wings folded close to its
body would have filled the chamber if it
spread them and when it turned its ugly
head toward them it roared with the
noise and made the rock tremble opened
its mouth and spat a jet of fire that
sent them running back up the passageway
this dragon is then used by the trio to
escape from gring Gods making their
Adventure into the bowels of the bank
one of the only known successful
breaches in its entire history
aside from this one incident however
Gringotts has been the premier
establishment for Magical Society to
keep their valuables safe since the 15th
century housing everything from gold to
joules treasure and even rare magical
artifacts like the Philosopher's Stone
and while our smuggles are acutely aware
of jewels and treasure the gold I'm
referring to here is not of the Muggle
variety although I'm sure some witches
and wizards do in fact choose to house
bars of gold and other items made of
pure gold in their vaults but no the
gold I'm referring to of course is the
gold Galleon the most valuable currency
in magical Society at least in Britain
cast by goblins each Galleon has a
series of numbers around its edges to
represent the goblin who made it
presumably this process of creating a
galleon is done exclusively by Gringotts
goblins as the heads sign of the coin is
stamped with the words Gringotts Bank on
the same side of this golden piece of
currency is also the head of a wizard
with the flip side of the coin known as
the tail side showcasing a dragon and
the words Unum galleon Unum is Latin and
may be interpreted as one meaning the
gold coins are imprinted with the words
one galleon
believed that the first batch of
galleons were cast sometime in the 1200s
as by the middle of the 13th century
they were in circulation throughout the
Wizarding community in Britain at this
point in time it's unclear whether or
not the Lesser value coins of modern
times existed yet today however there
are three different types of British
currency within the Wizarding World
including the gold Galleon in addition
to the Galleon there is also the silver
sickle and the bronze cannot the value
of each of these coins are 17 silver
sickles to a galleon and 29 canards to a
sickle
similarly to The Galleon the sickle and
the Canucks are both cast by Gringotts
goblins and have serial numbers
imprinted along their edges to signify
the goblin who made them and as you may
have guessed similarly to the Muggle
World The Wizarding World also has
various currencies across the globe in
America they use the dragon and in
France is believed the currency used by
witches and wizards is the bazant
while the general history of the French
present and when exactly it went into
circulation is unknown the American
Dragon is said to have been in use in
the United States since at least the
1700s there is also the possibility that
the dragon has a lesser value subunit
called the spring for those of you who
may be wondering what the conversion
rate is between muggle money and
Wizarding money you're not alone there
are entire websites dedicated to this
exact thing I've taken a deep dive into
some of these and last I checked one
Galleon was the equivalent of five
British pounds of course since there are
a many number of muggleborn witches and
wizards across the globe there is a
rather large population within the
Wizarding World which requires currency
exchange services as such Gringotts is
one of the only known places in the
entire world where muggleborns can
exchange their money for galleons
sickles and knuts we even see this
exchange process about to happen in
1992. when the Weasley family encounters
Hermione Granger and her muggle parents
on their way to exchange their British
pounds for Wizarding currency but your
Muggles said Mr Weasley delightedly we
must have a drink what's that you've got
there oh you're changing muggle money
Molly look he pointed excitedly at the
10 pound notes in Mr Granger's hand
presumably if the bank is willing to
exchange British pounds then they likely
also accept other foreign Mughal
currency as well as foreign magical
money although it hardly seems fair that
a muggle-born student attending ilver
morning School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry in the United States would need
to come all the way over to London in
order to exchange their American dollars
to targets hopefully the staff at
ilvermorny has some sort of unofficial
banking exchange system in place for
those students in any case currency that
is brought to Gringotts that is not
galleons sickles or canance is believed
to be dealt with by the Goblins who work
at the bank as these goblins are
responsible for casting and keeping the
primary currency of the British
Wizarding World it seems rather unlikely
that they would then keep muggle money
and other foreign currency on hand as
they wouldn't want it to compete with
their own coins it's therefore likely
that Gringotts and his goblins have a
process for reintegrating these
currencies back into circulation within
their various economies
since both muggle money and foreign
magical currency holds value they
obviously wouldn't just throw it away
altogether more likely at least to me is
the idea that perhaps goblins laundered
British pounds American dollars and
other Mughal currencies back out into
Mughal communities by way of France as
for the magical monies from other
countries they probably just sent that
back by way of some form of goblin magic
as with muggle money there are also
instances of counterfeit magical
currency the most common example of
counterfeit Wizarding money is
leprechaun gold these coins are said to
be made by leprechauns and are commonly
found among gamblers specifically at
quidditch matches although they closely
resemble real gold galleons and
sometimes make their way into
circulations within the Wizarding
economy they are distinctly different in
a number of ways for one leprechaun gold
will vanish after only a few hours these
coins can also be duplicated whereas
real galleons cannot be that said even
if leprechaun gold made its way to
Gringotts and lasted long enough for a
goblin to inspect it the employees of
the bank are easily able to tell them
apart from the real thing as seen by
Harry Ron and Hermione during their 1998
break-in the long counter was manned by
goblins sitting on high stools serving
the first customers of the day Hermione
Ron and Travers headed towards an old
Goblin was examining a thick gold coin
to an eye glass Hermione allowed Travis
to step ahead of her on the pretext of
explaining features of the hall to Ron
the goblin tossed the coin he was
holding aside said to nobody in
particular leprechaun and then greeted
Travis who passed over a tiny golden key
which was examined and given back to him
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think what
did I miss please share your thoughts in
the comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel who or
what should I cover the history of next
also be sure to check out the content on
Spotify as well as extra content on my
second Channel Harry Potter Theory extra
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign